[Music]
so we are really excited that you were
able to join us this morning because we
are going to tell you some very cool
things that you can do with nodejs and
sheets
my name is Francisca hinkelman I'm an
engineered Google in New York and I'm a
node core contributor and I'm also an
elected member of the nosiest technical
steering committee my co-presenter is a
new hi everyone my name is Anu
Srivastava I have been an engineer at
Google for over five years mainly in
cloud now I focus on key suite and I own
the developer experience for the G suite
editor so that's Docs sheets and slides
so let's get started with work less and
do more sheets for note developers when
you work with a sheet your typical
workflow is that you first collect the
data then you might have to do some
basic data prep like cleaning up time
zones or maybe translate user input that
you have in the sheet once you've
cleaned up your data you can now analyze
it which often goes hand in hand with
visualizing it why are we talking to you
about sheets
well sheets of this great advantage that
you can collaborate with anybody not
just developers sheets basically half
this universal language where anybody
can edit data enter data read the data
sorted filter it play around with it and
then draw their own conclusions from a
sheet not only can anybody work with a
sheet it's also really easy in sheets to
visualize your data in a chart you can
create all kinds of charts of course bar
charts column charts pie charts you name
it of course
as engineers we could be writing code
using a library like d3.js that creates
charts for us but that's a lot more work
and when I need to iterate quickly
sheets allow me to focus on the data the
trends and the correlations instead of
on the code because of this sheets is a
great tool if you want to experiment and
just prototype something probably not a
production tool but great for
prototyping if we're honest
entering and editing data in the sheet
is not always the most enjoyable task at
least if you don't do this on a regular
basis
luckily we can eliminate those manual
parts and we're going to show you know
exactly how you can do that and we love
node I here frenzy talking all the time
about how much she loves node how great
it is she really loves teaching people
how to use node and she loves her work
maintaining the node core honestly
before I started sitting next to Franzi
I primarily coded in Java and go but
after learning how async/await works I
have been converted so today we're going
to write a node application to work with
sheets so we're going to use the node
client library on the NPM registry this
has a full-fledged API for working with
sheets that we can use this is an aside
sheets is actually just one of the G
suite set of productivity tools you can
call these api's for free you don't need
an enterprise account and there's a lot
of stuff in here that maybe you use
every day like Gmail Drive Docs if
you've been watching a lot of the talks
on cloud you might have primarily heard
about GCP but Google Cloud is both G
sweet and GCP most of these api's are
generated the same way so they look and
feel pretty similar when you're working
with them you use the same account
they're in the same family you enable
the API is the same way so don't worry
if you're not a node person we have
client libraries SDKs and many languages
and it makes it easy to use these api's
in a canonical way so I already
mentioned Java and go but we have
everything from PHP to Ruby even dotnet
we'll be focusing on no today so let's
get started with a quick hello world so
we're gonna be writing a script that
could be running locally on maybe my
laptop my machine and it's talking to
the sheets service to make modifications
on my behalf
so we start by requiring the package
then we initialize the sheets client and
then right above there we see a long
string that is the authorization scope
so the scope is the level of access we
want to grant to our script I don't know
about you but when I'm installing a new
application I get really nervous when it
starts to ask for a lot of permission to
my user data you know if it wants full
access to my drive it wants to read my
emails I wants my location history shoe
size mother's maiden name social
security number it is really bad
practice to ask for more access to user
data than you actually need and we'll be
talking about best practices for off
later today and then also don't worry
about trying to like memorize the code
that we're gonna show you all that is on
github and then we will send out this
link after the talk so back to
HelloWorld
we make our call to actually write the
data then we need to tell the service
where to insert HelloWorld so in sheets
we specify cells by what we call it a1
notation so today we're actually just
writing into the very first cell we're
using modern syntax and once we run that
and if we go to the browser and actually
open the sheet this is what it looks
like we wrote to that very first cell
and if you remember from that API call
that we just showed you need to specify
the spreadsheet ID
well that ID conveniently is the same
one you find in the URL if you're
looking in the browser so if you're at
the point that you are using the sheets
API you're probably going to need to
write to more than just one style at a
time and the best way to do this is to
actually write group your write requests
together when it's possible we have this
concept called the batch update the
batch update method in many G suite
api's and it's the best way to make
modifications in bulk so
why should you group your requests
together with batching there are two
main reasons so the first is every time
any application makes like a network
halt there's a little bit of overhead
some latency for setting all that up and
receiving it when you group them
together you can actually reduce that
total latency for all those calls the
second is these api's are free to use
however you are bound by quota
restrictions so when you group them
together into a single request you'll be
using dramatically less quota so each
one of those tasks that you see those
can actually be a different type of
right and you can still group them
together so let's look at all these
different things you can do I think of
batch update as like a big fancy list or
like a bucket for all your different
modifications it's like a really big
hammer for many of the tasks that you
can do in the UI so we already saw that
you can write data we'll be talking a
lot about adding charts today and you
can do other things like even add
developer metadata so now that we have a
basic toolkit for working with the sheet
service let's actually try to solve a
real world problem so I sit next to
Francie and I frequently see her looking
at the insights tab for the node core
repo so this is a repo that has the
node.js runtime she is very concerned
with the health of this repo the
insights tab gives you a lot of metrics
about you know the number of issues and
pull requests over time however this tab
only gives you insights into what's
going on within github but if you've
ever had a long day at work you know
that there are many different things
that go into how productive we are you
can't really see things like oh are
people being blocked by the Jenkins CI
and that's reducing the number of pull
requests they could be making you can't
see if maybe they're stuck in traffic
that's why they can't close issues
there's a lot of things happening
what is just how well-fed people are
dramatically affects their productivity
frenzy wants to get a holistic picture
into what helps people be more
productive so let's focus in on one of
those questions that we're very curious
about but that's kind of hard to define
we're gonna go a little silly today so
bear with us we want to experiment and
see if we can see if food satisfaction
yields better github metrics so this is
a hard problem not from a technical
perspective but like a real-world
perspective we have our contributors at
their machines we have github and we
have the food we want an application to
tie it all together so we can automate
gathering these metrics which is why
we're going to use sheet so we can
quickly manipulate that data we're going
to write some code in node to monitor
the node repo so let's get started by
breaking this down so my idea is that we
work brother if we're well fat but we
want to see the metrics let's look at
the data to prove this first thing we
have to do is collected data as a new
set we're going to get this from the
github repository we are specifically
interested in how many pour requests are
merged how many issues are close and
overall how many open issues and pull
requests do we have so how do we get
this data while a github has a very nice
REST API and if we use octo kid to get
her breast API client for JavaScript
it's very easy to get this data and the
API gives us exactly the same data that
we would get in the insights tab so it's
really just a few very straightforward
API calls to get this data
programmatically and once we have the
data from github we will write it to a
spreadsheet so just like in the hello
world example where we wrote hello world
now we're writing the numbers that we
got from github of course I could have
console.log the results from github
copied that and then manually pasted it
into a spreadsheet but that's manual I
might be making mistakes I don't want to
do it so I'm using an 8
I call now on to the food part we love
metrics and surveys so we did a survey
and the survey we figure out how happy
the contributors are with their food on
a daily basis super-scientific
every time you use a Google Form the
results are automatically written to a
spreadsheet so here we just configure
the form to use the same spreadsheet
that we also use for our right cause of
the github data all right now that we
have the data both we get hub and for
food now we are interested in whether
there are any correlations if we are
hungry do we close more issues because
we want to get done and leaves you get
food or if we had too much food are we
much slower and we don't merge any poor
requests or if we're hangry maybe we
just open issue after issue how can we
see these correlations well a quick way
is with a chart so let's do that here's
the chart we look at the results later
for now we're just interested in how we
get this chart of course you can go to
the sheet highlight it and then click
add chart but we don't want to do this
manually so we will use an API call
let's see what the code for this looks
like so if we want to create a chart we
have to create an ad charge request this
our child request has a chart and we
have to pass in the specification for
the chart once we've built our request
then we're using our friend batch update
to send this ad shot request future
parameters I want to point out here one
thing you have to specify is the type so
we are creating a line chart then you
need to domain the domain is your x-axis
so in our case that's the date we want
to see how are the trends changing over
time so we put the date as the domain
and then probably the most important
part of a chart is the series the data
series so in our case the numbers we got
from github how many issues and pull
requests so our architecture overall
looks like this we have two data sources
we pull the data and we write it to a
spreadsheet and then the sheet creates a
chart for us and we're doing all of this
luckily we're not opening a sheet and
run anything inside the sheet all this
note code runs on our on our machine we
can control the node version that we're
running and it's just interacting with a
REST API and Anu is now going to take
this one step further yeah so we're
gathering the data and we're getting
insights however it's only running
locally on a machine
so only one team member has access to it
we should really host this as a service
we are in the cloud track after all so
ideally this would be a fully fledged
app with a client and a server but we
actually know that it's really not just
those two parts if you want to get like
all those good principles that we have
in cloud like high availability fault
tolerance we probably need to add
multiple servers when you have multiple
servers you probably need a load
balancer to distribute those requests
maybe you need a cache somewhere there's
like a lot of different pieces that you
need to set up to have like a real
server frenzy and I only want to focus
on our code not the infrastructure so we
decide to go investigate other options
this is how we land on server list in
GCP so with server list you just get to
upload your code and then the cloud
provider figures out how to place and
scale it on your behalf we don't need to
know or even really want to know
anything about the machines that our
code is running on and you only have to
pay for the time that your code is
running so this is really great because
to do a fetch of all the data and
produce a chart it doesn't take more
than a few minutes but if we were to put
this on a VM we'd probably be paying for
that to just sit there idly 24/7 then
open over there it just means that you
get to use the tools and the frameworks
and the languages they are already
familiar with since we're working with
no today we're going to be using the
Express framework if you're working with
Python you'd be using flask and all of
those good pairs so there's a few
different products in the server list
family we
try to go with crowd functions so club
functions in a nutshell they are narrow
focus bits of code that you upload to
Google and then you trigger them by
events so we have a background events
that they respond to some of your other
cloud services you can think of them as
like glue for connecting all these
pieces maybe you trigger an event by
uploading some files to your GCS bucket
maybe you're listening to incoming
pub/sub messages we're actually going to
be working with HTTP functions today
those are more common and they are
triggered by what you'd probably expect
HTTP requests they're really good for
things were you needing either process
data like us or maybe you're calling
external services so in the real world
people use them for things like okay I
want to do credit card payments so maybe
I'm talking to stripe maybe I want to
send text messages so I'll be using
Twilio let's look at a quick hello world
for HTTP functions so I keep saying the
word function is that really what I mean
yes with two lines of code you have a
fully operational back-end after you
deploy this you don't need any
additional configuration like a gateway
with Google Cloud functions you get a
fully provision endpoint on a fully
qualified domain and this handles that
self search for you and we mentioned to
add the framework so those request and
response objects those are from these
fresh framework so now that we know a
little bit about crop functions we're
going to keep that code that we had in
our first version we're just going to
wrap it up and us our local script and
then deploy it so we have a serverless
back-end for our system this service
will read our data from our external
sources and then produce a chart all
while running in the data center
somewhere in the cloud so we upload the
code that we already have together with
an exported function will call it github
chart and then that calls our main logic
so after all that processing
done we send a 200 status code just like
in hello world and then here we're going
to send back the ID of the spreadsheet
which has our chart so how do we deploy
this function that sounds like it might
be hard or scary it's actually really
easy you can use the G cloud CLI the G
cloud CLI is a tool that you can use to
manage all your DCP tasks so with
functions you just have to pass in the
name of your exported function so that's
why we see github chart again so it
uploads your code it picks up your
package JSON not the node modules
themselves so this is really nice if you
have so data connections
it's just picking up your source code
and then it built it in the cloud for
you we can also edit and deploy the
function straight from the cloud console
as well the cloud console is the web
interface where you manage your cloud
services and then you turn on api's and
look at all your monitoring and stuff
like that so the code is in the cloud
but it still needs to be triggered
manually by a human we want to keep
pulling in this data regularly and keep
tracking our productivity over time so
instead of needing a person to trigger
this function every day we can actually
schedule the function by using cloud
scheduler in my opinion cloud scheduler
is just big fancy cron in the cloud we
set up this cron job in the cloud
console as well you use the same syntax
as as if you were using basic cron we
have hours to set at run set to run
every morning at 9:00 a.m. and then down
at the bottom we specify that HTTP URL
we got back from cob functions so now we
have a back-end job to do all of our
data collection and Franzese gonna take
you through adding a client so when we
trigger an HTTP endpoint our code is run
on a function but for more functionality
it would be nice if we had a front-end
client so we don't
to memorize a bunch of HTTP endpoints so
we add a client that sends out emails to
the team with the new chart and since
we're dealing with emails we're going to
use the Gmail API for this task let's
look at our front-end code for this so
just like in the back end with nodejs we
have client libraries on the front end
and then for Gmail if you som want to
send an email it's really
straightforward Gmail that uses that
messages that sent you have to include
your raw email here that's just base 64
encoded of your content which could be
plain text or HTML so now we have the
front-end or a cron job triggering the
cloud function which pulls a new data
and creates a chart and when that is
done then the front-end will send out an
email with this new chart everybody on
the team I set the whole story though
just kidding we left out auth
authorization you don't want others to
send out emails on your behalf and you
don't want anybody to read and write
your spreadsheets so let's have a look
how we do authorization in our
application in the front end we have an
authorized or login button that triggers
the Google sign-in flow Google sign-in
is a secure authentication system that
allows users to log in with their Google
account that they already have and then
they can authorize your app to use
Google services like Gmail on behalf of
them in a secure manner Google uses the
OAuth 2 protocol so the way this works
is your application asks for user
consent like you just saw and only then
it can access you to user data so the
key point here is that your application
with ours to you does not have does
never ask for the users credentials
it only gets consent to then access user
data on behalf of the user
so remember earth to its consent instead
of credentials let's look at how the
protocol works in detail this
authorization flow
also called three-leg hours the entities
are your JavaScript front-end the Google
service and the end user that's
consenting so when you want to access
user data you first send a request to
the Google auth server and then the end
user has to log in and consent if they
did that successfully then you get a
token from the our server and now you
can use this choken for all your
requests to the Google API it's like
Gmail to send emails on behalf of that
end user luckily the client libraries
handle this for us so we don't have to
worry about the implementation details
of three-legged OAuth one thing that you
have to specify when you initialize the
client the Google API squared is the
Scopes and you already mentioned them
earlier for sheets so now we're using
the Gmail that sent scope so that means
when you request the Gmail that send
scope when the user goes through the
Google sign-in then it actually says do
you allow this app to send emails on
your behalf and if users approve that
the token that we get back from the
o'the server is only good for this scope
if I take the so Kenard and I'm like oh
I'm gonna attach your sheets and I get a
4:3 because that's not what the user
consented you obviously you always want
to keep the scope as restrictive as
possible there's lots of different
scopes definitely have a look at them if
you're working with the Google API I
want to quickly point out this one scope
drive that file this is really nice
because instead of granting access to
all your sheets for example you only
granting permission to the app to touch
the sheets that the app itself
created what may be explicitly was given
permission so this is a good one because
users don't have to worry that your app
can read all their documents alright so
in the front end we have a login button
and then this consent screen pops up and
the end user has to click so that you
can access that you can send emails on
behalf of the users how are we handling
us in our back-end we decided that our
back-end so the part where the cloud
function talks to the Google sheet will
not have any end users involved instead
we have the
the sheet belongs to the application so
our back end is not accessing a news
sheet on my sheet its accessing a sheet
that actually belongs to this
application and we're doing server to
server authorization here heads after if
you're working with the G speed API best
practices that you should work with user
with user credentials and three-legged
hours usually you don't want the
documents to belong to the application
so in the backend we have to elect hours
we have two entities we have the backend
of your application and the Google
servers there's no end-user
involved here and server-to-server
authentication uses JSON web tokens jots
to request a token from the Google auth
server and then I can use that token to
access the Google API but this time on
behalf of the application not on behalf
of somebody else again here use the
client libraries they wrap this workflow
for you so you don't have to create and
sign your own JSON web token comparing a
three-legged and Q leg oath so three
like ours has is always on behalf of an
end-user and it requires consent from
this end user and 4G speed API expect
for best practices to use three leg
hours - like ours on the other hand is
server to server authorization and the
requests are made on behalf of the
application and the resources belong to
the application not your end-users and
under the hood - like authors using JSON
web tokens thank you for that really
detailed comparison about the different
types of ah
so like Francie said these are this is
all handled for you by our client
libraries if you choose to use them if
you look at the quick starts in our
documentation they actually show you how
to get set up with this in just a few
steps it's really important to use OAuth
because now you're working with tokens
not people's actual passwords we don't
want people storing them especially not
in plain
texts so now that we have all that set
up what is the whole point of writing
this application it was to see if we can
get insights into if food satisfaction
boosts our github productivity so let's
look at some of those charts more
closely we made a lot of charts with our
sample data that we were running through
April we can see a bit of a correlation
so this chart has all the different
metrics that we were tracking the
left-hand side has the scale of the
number of issues open issues so that's
in the hundreds but then on the right
hand side we have the scale of the PRS
and our food satisfaction so if you
remember that survey it was from one to
five let's look at some more charts that
break this down a little bit further so
if we look at pull requests specifically
looks like we merge PR as one we're a
better fed again these line charts shows
trends a lot more quickly than if you're
trying to look at these numbers in your
console so especially this one I like
this one because it shows close issues
and merged PRS those are like our
completed tasks so after we write this
code we never have to manually open
sheets again to get our insights now
that we have this data we could easily
add data for more sources you know say
we could actually get traffic commute
times more realistically things that you
probably already have maybe some other
internal systems that you're using
application monitoring other api's that
you have around you know how to add
stuff into sheets
so in conclusion good food yields good
code and now we have the data to back it
up if anybody wants the proof we're
going to tack on one last thing to our
system so another workflow that we see a
lot is people having to create reports
regularly of data just like this maybe
for their managers or team meetings that
you frequently have and I don't know too
many people who are really jazzed about
making reports so let's see if we can do
some automation so yeah these reports
you might have to make
weekly monthly quarterly maybe you know
some salespeople who make these types of
reports for their clients they could be
in a side tack they could be in a Google
Doc maybe we just want to prove our good
food trend over time so we share this
info with people all across the company
and a doc that's quickly easy to look at
so maybe you specifically don't have to
do this but maybe you probably know
someone who does and you can make them
really happy by scripting this as well
so let's look at a sample report and
then see how we can automate this with
the api's that we are already using if
you've ever had to do this sort of thing
yourself maybe the first thing you do is
create a copy of an old one and then you
start manually updating that data this
can be super tedious it can be really
error-prone and it's easy to miss pieces
of data that you need to update and then
well what if you use a template
templates are pretty common but you
still have to do some manual work so
we're going to completely automate this
you can use the drive API to make a copy
for you and then we'll use slides to
actually merge in all that data we'll
look at some of the pieces a day that
we're going to update for example on our
first slide we have the report generated
date so we're going to create a size API
client this syntax should look really
familiar
and then that date that we saw on that
first slide we can actually make a
replace all text requests to update it
with today's date and you guessed it
replace all text is a type of batch
update and we can do this for other text
placeholders you can replace any sort of
text I just happen to use all caps with
curly brackets so I know what are
placeholders but maybe we had a slide
summarizing the total number of pour
requests and issues so now let's look at
how to add our charts that we made
what's really nice about these API is is
that they're tightly coupled together
the same way that the products are so
slides has a method call create
it's chart and you can get the sheet by
its or the chart by its chart ID which
you can get via the sheets API and then
if you add write a script with all of
these different code snippets you can
completely automate generating a report
with no human intervention this could
save you or your co-workers hours and
hours of time so now that we've added
reporting let's take a step back and
look at the system that we designed
today we designed a basic reporting
system using node and our G suite and G
C PAP is so our front-end triggers a
cloud function that fetches data from
external sources and creates a chart now
we have multiple ways of sharing this
information either via email or a report
at its core we're using sheets as a data
manipulation and collection tool so our
experimental app investigates if lunch
affects our productivity we know this
probably isn't exactly what you or your
company needs right now you probably
already have dashboards and analytics
but what we really wanted to do was
inspire you to be creative and think of
maybe some non-technical problems and
solve it with the tools that you are
probably already using every day we
really hope you have fun coding on your
next project with nodejs our completed
code is on github so feel free to tweet
at us and let us know what you think
thank you everyone for tuning in on the
live stream and for everyone here today
we would love to answer your questions
right outside we look forward to meeting
you and have a great time with Rosso bio
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]